hello hello we're going to talk about
black history
[Music]
Harriet Tubman
she's just my hero she helped everyone
out when they needed it and she just
saved everyone she snuck them out and
she used the Big Dipper and free
everyone let's go we will be free we'll
just go at night with all of you and go
to the Underground Railroad and we'll go
be free and go together thank you so
much I really wanted to leave I don't
know how long I could stay here but
thank you so much you are a hero to us
all we shall be free let's go
hey journey what was life when a black
people back in the day well it'll be
certain sections where they would have
to be able to sit lady you can't sit
here oh yeah yeah you say that you don't
tell me what to do either cuz this is my
bus Rosa Parks you're going to jail yeah
like nobody hello cop yes I am here and
it's black person won't leave and just
come here in five minutes please thank
you it was right that black people
should sit in the front bus to Martin
Luther King jr. he is best known for
advancing the civil rights movement and
I have a dream speech and it talked
about beating whites and blacks together
and making it a better place I have a
dream that brothers and sisters would
unite there would be no more Wars no
more killing we would all have the same
people education equal opportunity and
we'd all unite as one Malcolm X with the
civil rights activist and he was a
spokesman for the Nation of Islam he
believed to use the method of by any
means necessary
he changed his beliefs and he just
wanted a
to be together in peace just as Martin
Luther King wanted so basically all
black historic figures aren't in some
way the same because they all wanted the
same thing for us to come together in
peace
[Music]